[موسيقى]
أحد أسباب رغبتي في القدوم
إلى الأولمبوس هو أنني سمعت
أن المرأة كانت مسؤولة عن
مجتمع أمومي وأردت أن أعرف
كيف يمكن أن يكون الأمر أكثر قليلًا من أن
أكون امرأة  الاسم هو
Katie sail
، أنا أصلاً من تورنتو وأنا
كاتب ومحرر ، لذلك نحن في سجاد
وهي جزيرة يونانية هناك
شيء محير قليلاً حول
الهبوط هنا لديك شعور
بأنك على حافة  العالم ، وبمجرد
وصولك إلى هنا ، إذا كنت ترغب في
زيارة أوليمبوس ، فهذه أيضًا رحلة أخرى
استقرت في الجبال ، لذا فهي
معزولة قليلاً ، ومن الصعب الوصول إليها
سواء كنت ستصل إلى هناك بالسيارة أو
بالقارب.  التي لاحظت حقًا
أن الرجال كانوا أكثر هدوءًا ،
وكانت النساء هم من يتفاعلون معي
بشكل مباشر أكثر لمشاركة آرائهم
معي ، وكان الرجال يفعلون ذلك أيضًا ،
لكنهم كانوا نوعًا ما يأخذون المقعد الخلفي
قليلاً وهو ما كان ممتعًا
[موسيقى]
منذ سنوات عديدة  عندما كان رجالهم في
الخارج ال  كان على المرأة أن
تبقى وتهتم بميراثها
الأرض المنزل وأن تكون مسؤولة عن كل شيء من
النساء هنا فينا جميعًا الذين اعتادوا
القيام بالزراعة والقيام بزراعة
الأرض حتى اكتسبوا القوة وكان عليهم أن يكونوا
جيدين في  الاقتصاد وفي كل شيء
لإدارة المنزل والبقاء على قيد الحياة في هذه
البيئة الطهي وتعلم الخبز
مع المرأة هنا حقًا كان له
ملاحظة خاصة بالنسبة لي لأن لديهم
تقليدًا قويًا للغاية في مشاركة الوصفات التي
تعلمتها والدتي من
جدتي وجدتي  أمي
أروني وأريكم البنات وكلهم
يذهبون دائمًا هكذا كانت جدتي
تصنع الأشياء من الصفر طوال
الوقت ولم أتعلم وصفاتها
أبدًا ولم تكتبها أبدًا
وهذا شيء شعرت دائمًا
بالندم  لذلك أعتقد أن التعلم من
والديك وأجدادك أمر مهم للغاية ، لذا فإن
شيئًا
كهذا يتطلب تدريبًا ، وتخصص القليل من الوقت
لتتعلم نعم ، لكنني أصنعها ستة كيلوغرامات من
الطحين.  هل لديك
شيء تقوله قبل أن تأكل
مثل Bon Appetit باللغة اليونانية Callie أو
تتجاوز Callie و Oryx ، هذا هو
ماكرون يمكنك أن
تخبرني أن أي مكان تذهب إليه
يجب أن تذهب إليه بانفتاح لا
تقارن به  من أين أتيت ليس
للحكم ولكن للتعلم والانفتاح لتجربة
أشياء جديدة ورؤية الأشياء بشكل مختلف
وداعًا ، آمل أن تنمو السياحة
هنا لأنني أعتقد أن هذا
شيء تحتاجه الجزيرة وشيء
يريده الناس هنا ولكنه أيضًا
مكان يجب أن تذهب إليه بنية ،
ونتيجة لذلك أعتقد أنه من الأسهل بكثير
التواصل مع الأشخاص الذين يعيشون
هنا وأعتقد أن هذا هو ما
يدور حوله السفر